there's so many people who are a hundred
percent convinced that
this is the case and that she's leaving
when i'm like there's absolutes there's
also a lot of counter arguments as to
why she wouldn't be
leaving
[Music]
oh brie larson's in the title of a
youtube video
who's in the comments on this one right
the way this always goes all the nuanced
discussions are taking place i can feel
it already
look guys this might surprise you this
might surprise everyone on the internet
we don't hate brie larson oh i was sure
you did
i i don't i mean i'm sexist but i don't
hate breathing arson that's the odd part
about her right look here's my honest
opinion getting this stuff out of the
way i think brie larson
is a great actress i do not hate
the individual the human being brie
larson
i don't really care for her captain
marvel portrayal at the same time
there i am not that endeared to it i was
i like the movie
i do overall i do i'm not drawn to her
portrayal all right i'll keep it at that
but that doesn't mean i'm infuriated by
her
no we're gonna talk about a few things
ever since
that marvel trailer came out and they
declared it
that it's not going to be called captain
marvel 2 but called marvel's maybe it's
just because greg and john with their
real rejects algorithm feed
all these videos and articles keep
popping up in our feed about how
brie larson reportedly leaving captain
marvel now
marvel wants her gone all that kind of
jazz right and
i feel like i've been hearing that for
the longest time uh but especially
lately i've been hearing that almost
non-stop
so i kind of wanted to talk about it and
i wanted to kind of look at both sides
here all right so first off here's the
main report that's been going around
marvel reportedly wants brie larson out
and they're going to replace her
with two characters reportedly being
monica rambo
and uh kamala hair nope whoop
that would be like the third time i've
done that in my life kamala gone
it's so natural just to go there now you
it had me thinking like but what does
that mean that they'd be replacing
captain marvel with that what does that
mean exactly like to draw comparison
here let's look at falcon and winter
soldier with replacing
captain america there's so much of an
identity
emotional association this iconography
towards who captain america is what it
means to be captain america
the symbolism to take up the mantle
there's so much associated with the
ideologies of
who captain america is that to
do a whole thing of taking up the mantle
of captain america there's a lot to
explore there you say that with captain
marvel
i'm like what the hell is that what is
that like what is the mantle
what is the mantle of captain marvel
like i don't know what that is
at least in the mcu yeah maybe in the
comics there's something there
but in the mcu i personally am like
i i couldn't tell you what that means
being a being a superhero that's about
as far as it goes she just got here
yeah right that's about as far as it
goes so we don't really know what it is
or does that mean when people are saying
they're going to replace it
that means they're not going to do
captain marvel anymore they're just
going to do
you know the marvels and it's just going
to be monica rambo
and kamala khan khan it's just going to
be them so no more captain marvel just
marvels
them one of them's going to become cat
tomorrow like there's a bunch of
questions just sort of
sprung up from like what does this all
really entail and then you got to go
back to is brie larson really leaving
is that what's really happening because
if if my memory serves me correct
there was a time where there was all
these reports coming out that brie
larson
was pushing to have more uh inclusivity
and also uh to have a an ensemble
all-female cast so when i heard marvel's
i'm like this is what brie larson was
like
she wanted it to do right that's what i
thought yeah that's the fascinating
thing about this is you know i mean
it's impossible i think to ignore the
backlash against brie larson and hey
i mean marvel has to be aware of that
too so it's like on the one hand i don't
think they are
they don't pay attention to anything
they are so
blind one day kevin feige is going to
type
brie larson in on youtube be like what
is this
wow i had no idea get the casting people
on the phone i think that they are smart
enough to be aware and and the thing is
that with brie larson yeah she only has
done the one movie so far in the one
appearance in avengers end game and so
there is a lot to develop there and like
you said with
steve rogers captain america there's
already such an
iconography in history that even like
the lay person who's not a comics reader
knows a little bit about and then on top
of that you've got chris evans
over several movies and phases of the
mcu for people to get endeared to
so it's like i understand how the
narrative pops off of people going well
marvel they must hate her if they're
gonna pivot at all with this franchise
because the first one wasn't perfect
it is important to note that this seems
like exactly what bruce larson wanted
and it also is a tentative move it would
seem like to me because they dropped
this you know log line or this plot
description recently that basically says
ah
the marvel's captain marvel two it's
going to be about carol dan verza she's
going up against a big thing
she needs some help who should get it
from these two
that's the logo yeah so it's just pretty
much a confirmation that we'll have
these three in an ensemble capacity and
also with the miss marvel
character not that i'm an expert by any
stretch i haven't read
a comic of miss marvel but i do know
that miss marvel has strong associations
her origin to captain marvel directly so
it just makes sense that she would be in
it
yeah absolutely and hey the other thing
too is that you know
people rest almost all of their ire
toward
anything to do with that first captain
marvel movie on the shoulders of pre
larsen squarely
but i think if you look at a lot of the
reviews you'll find that a lot of people
and we even shared this opinion to
varying degrees
say that with carol danvers in that
movie
part of the lack is in the scripting and
the amount of scenes they give her to
develop and endear us to her as a
character
most of that work is given to supporting
characters
yeah with that in mind let's transition
to uh playing a little bit of devil's
advocate here
because here's the other side
i could also see how
some of these reports are true because
if you go on look out of any superhero
lead in the marvel cinematic universe
undoubtedly
brie larson is the most controversial
one she is
like i think it's that's an objective
that's a fact
that's not some opinion i have i think
the
the endearment towards captain marvel or
you know carol danvers the character
isn't as strong as one might hoped i
mean
some people really love her i think
generally speaking it's just not as
strong but you know you got like
sites like giant freaking robot we got
this
cosmic book yeah all these things just
keep popping up
all your favorite channels but even like
scoopers that are reliable like
apparently daniel rpk had said something
about this also being the case that bree
larson wants to move on from here i can
see brie larson wanting to move on
because of the fact of how
maybe she doesn't feel accepted by the
marvel community and then you know
grace randolph also chiming in saying
that marvel wasn't happy and they did
replace the filmmakers ultimately
going forward with the sequel so there's
a lot of variables where i could also
see like
oh yeah it's probably maybe it is true
that they they wanted
i just think it's kind of silly there's
so many people who are
a hundred percent convinced that this is
the case and that she's leaving when i'm
like
there's absolutely there's also a lot of
counter arguments as to why she wouldn't
be
leaving that one percent chance man you
gotta act on that one percent
yeah right now i don't believe it i
don't
however i could also see it being the
other k
i'm just saying i i could see both sides
here but if you want me to take a stance
right now i don't believe it no i don't
either i feel like they're
certainly in a position where they're
going to play a bit more by ear and see
if they can
really get her two people in the right
way before making it
and they got a new director in here they
got a new people working on this gonna
be a very different movie than the first
captain marvel
i feel and brie larson has demonstrated
with previous roles that she is a very
talented oscar-winning actress she can
act so maybe in this one she can
you know deliver something that we have
that we didn't get from the first one
you know that plays on those chops
i'm always down for improvement even
finn jones got a little better for iron
fist season two
danny rand all right guys
do you believe this what's your take on
it do you even really give a [ __ ] leave
your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
last but not least
adelia chamberlain right now you want me
to come on your showdown uh
the show that you help produce and host
now which i'm so proud of you still for
being on camera a lot more i don't know
yet if i can attend it it's uh shaping
into quite
busy busy days lately but i wanted to
show you on this specific video because
you are someone who is always fighting
the good fight always fighting for
equality you are a big
marvel fan you're a big geek and you're
smarter than i've ever been
and you are also more you're stronger
than i've ever been
i admire you and look up to you and you
have moved me in more ways than you
realize
you rock if there's anyone who's a
captain marvel
at our patreon
you up is pointing to you it's you
i saw the monitor i thought you were
pointing at me and no no since you're
not once in a while john
i love you adelia that sounds sarcastic
adelia why didn't you invite me on this
show
of course